[Musik]
gemeinsames gedenken in einer
berührenden trauerfeier erinnern die
spitzen des staates und angehörige an
die korona opfer die uhr tickt heute
endet die selbst gesetzte frist zwischen
armin laschet und markus söder wer von
beiden kanzlerkandidat der union werden
soll und chaos rennen von ihm ua auf der
heimstrecke von ferrari jubelt red bull
pilot max verstand
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne für
den sport hallo guten 83 millionen
corona tote sind es bisher weltweit
allein in deutschland starben fast
80.000 menschen viele einsam weil ihre
angehörigen nicht zu ihnen durften um
die trauer zu teilen hat bundespräsident
steinmeier eine gedenkfeier initiiert
mit dem appell lassen wir nicht zu dass
die pandemie die uns schon als menschen
zum abstand zwingt uns auch als
gesellschaft auseinander treibt
christian ritscher den toten ein gesicht
geben mit einer emotional inszenierten
gedenkfeier im berliner konzerthaus will
der stadt ein zeichen der anteilnahme
senden trost spenden nicht immer nur auf
anonyme kurven und statistiken schauen
mahnte der bundespräsident
[Musik]
mein eindruck ist dass wir uns als
gesellschaft nicht oft genug bewusst
machen dass hinter all den zahlen
schicksale menschen stehen
eine gesellschaft die dieses leid
verdrängt wird als ganzes schaden nehmen
fünf angehörige erzählen stellvertretend
von ihren verlust sowie anita schädel
aus passau die vor einem jahr ihren mann
hannes durch ko witt 19 verlor von der
intensivstation liefern mich noch einmal
an ich werde jetzt ins künstliche koma
versetzt und beatmet noch dir keine
sorgen ich bin in den besten händen
du kannst mich bald wieder abholen ich
freue mich auf dich das war unser
letztes gespräch ein gedenken im
kleinsten kreis nur die spitzen der fünf
verfassungsorgane sein zeigen ihr seid
nicht allein
und es wird nicht nur der korona toten
gedacht finja wilkens verlor ihren vater
an krebs
auch für sie das schlimmste ihm beim
abschied in pandemie zeiten nicht nahe
sein zu können
wir wollten es nicht und doch haben wir
ihn alleine gelassen kein kontakt kein
einblick kein hand halten oder einfach
da sein
es war die hölle für uns überall im land
heute kerzen und schweigeminuten wie
hier im saarland oder baumpflanzungen
wie auf diesem wuppertaler friedhof und
deutschlandweit wehen die flaggen auf
halbmast für ein gedenken in unsicherer
zeit und auch heute kommen weitere
schicksale dazu das robert koch institut
registrierte 19.000 185 neuinfektionen
binnen eines tages
1330 mehr als vor einer woche
die zahlen am wochenende sind meist
etwas niedriger
es gibt 67 weitere todesfälle die
bundesweite sieben tage incident steigt
auf 162,3 zum kanzlerkandidaten duell in
der union sollten die beiden parteichefs
ihre zusage anfang der woche ernst
gemeint haben
dann müssten wir eigentlich jeden moment
erfahren wer von beiden verzichtet
der ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen armin laschet oder
sein kollege aus bayern markus söder
weil aber offenbar immer noch keiner so
recht weiß was wird steigt die
nervosität
der machtkampf in der union spitzt sich
offenbar zu
heute abend wollen sowohl der
niedersächsische landesverband als auch
die junge union ihr votum bekanntgeben
der druck auf söder und laschet sich
endlich zu einigen steigt glaube das ist
schon wichtig ist um das ganze jetzt
nicht zu sehr in die länge zu ziehen
dass das anfang der woche jetzt auch mal
geklärt ist glaube die menschen wollen
auch ein signal haben das ist nach einer
erklärung einer personalfrage jetzt
nochmal mit voller kraft an die
sachfragen geht und deswegen setze ich
darauf dass das jetzt gelingt söder
gegen laschet fast schon im stundentakt
werden beide kandidaten von jeweils
anderen lager aufgefordert zurück zu
ziehen um eine abstimmung in der
fraktion zu verhindern gibt es einen
neuen vorschlag
die andere alternative wäre dass die
parteien beschließen wirklich ein
mitgliederentscheid in cdu und csu
durchzuführen gemeinsam das wahlergebnis
wäre auch bis pfingsten spätestens das
war ja der termin den sich beide gesetzt
hatten
da und wenn basis dann richtig basis
noch aber geht der machtkampf weiter und
noch immer droht die spaltung der union
der theo koll in berlin die uhr tickt
fragt sich nur in welche richtung nun
noch geht das richtung scherbenhaufen
manche in der cdu sagen sogar dass
richtung blutbad die selbst gesetzte
frist läuft aus hinter beiden kämpfern
haben sich truppen versammelt aber es
ist kein mechanismus erkennbar wie die
weitere vergrößerung des schadens noch
verhindert werden könnte heute abend
schalten sich die landesvorsitzende der
jungen union und auch die cdu
niedersachsen zusammen und am ende
werden sie zu truppen für die eine oder
andere seite das heißt die gräben in der
cdu werden tiefer und sichtbarer
vielleicht könnte die autorität von
angela merkel noch den maximalen schaden
verhindern helfen indem sie einen von
beiden den rückzug von der kandidatur
nahelegt ansonsten droht in der fraktion
die offene entscheidungsschlacht
vielen dank klare einschätzung von theo
koll aus berlin und mehr dazu gibt's in
berlin direkt gleich nach uns zwischen
china und den usa stehen die zeichen
eigentlich eher auf konfrontation beim
klimaschutz allerdings wollen sie
zusammenarbeiten
das ist das ergebnis von gesprächen des
amerikanischen klimabeauftragten carey
mit seinem chinesischen kollegen diese
woche die beiden länder stoßen mehr als
40 prozent aller schädlichen
treibhausgase weltweit aus die usa haben
russland mit konsequenzen gedroht sollte
kreml-kritiker navalny im russischen
straflager sterben seine ärzte fürchten
einen herzstillstand der 44 jährige ist
seit mehr als zwei wochen im
hungerstreik um zu erreichen dass ein
mediziner seiner wahl zu ihm darf nach
den usa und polen weist jetzt auch
tschechien russische diplomaten aus die
18 russen seinen agenten heißt es aus
prag ein diplomatischer paukenschlag auf
den moskau kommt reagiert die ausweisung
sei absurd und feindselig hintergrund
sind explosionen im tschechischen
munitionslagern 2014
britta hilpert berichtet in den
tschechischen wäldern bei wurde btc
liegen überreste von munitionslagern die
nun für diplomatische spannungen sorgen
2014 explodierten hier munition und
waffen die wohl in die ukraine geliefert
werden sollten
zwei menschen starben es war russische
sabotage sagt die tschechische regierung
die beweise unserer sicherheitsdienste
begründen den verdacht dass der
russische militärgeheimdienst gru
involviert ist so der tschechische
ministerpräsident barbisch gestern 18
russische botschaftsangehörige werden
nun des landes
vor der botschaft einige proteste auch
bei moskau mit gegenmaßnahmen brot und
sagt dieser feindliche schrittfolge
einer serie antirussischer aktionen
durch tschechien
in den letzten jahren klar erkennbar sei
auch eine verbindung zu den usa
gemeinsames vorgehen von nato und eu sei
nun nötig meint der tschechische
außenminister wir rechnen mit der
solidarität unserer alliierten die
explosionen von foto getty zu werden
schon morgen im eu außenrat thema sein
jetzt zum sport du bist von rudi mit
radsport jetzt los maximilian schach man
hat beim radsport frühjahrsklassiker
amstel gold race den dritten platz
belegt der berliner schafft auf den 217
kilometern durch den südlichsten zipfel
der niederlande den sprung in die
spitzengruppe mit dem belgier baut von
arzt und dem jungen briten thomas pöck
zwei sprintern von art siegt ganz knapp
einer reifen stärke entscheidet für den
belgier borussia dortmund bleibt mit dem
3 2 1 lag und zwei harland tor gegen
werder bremen auf tabellenplatz fünf der
abstand zu frankfurt und dem champions
league platz hat sich auf vier punkte
verändert der vorstand des fc bayern
rückt seinen trainer in einer
presseerklärung missbilligt er die
einseitige kommunikation von hansi flick
der gestern öffentlich verkündet hat
dass er eine vertragsauflösung möchte
und die frankfurterinnen katharina
steinruck hat mit ihrem marathon sieg im
niederländischen enschede das olympia
ticket in reichweite mit zwei stunden 25
minuten 59 sekunden verbessert sie
deutlich ihre bestzeit und liegt jetzt
aussichtsreich im rennen um die drei
tokio tickets war bier schöneborn aus
berlin wird dritter
max daten gewinnt den großen preis der
emilia romagna in imola der niederländer
triumphiert vor weltmeister lewis
hamilton in einem turbulenten rennen
diese kollision zwischen dem britischen
verursacher länder norris und dem
leidtragenden valtteri bottas führt zu
einer halbstündigen unterbrechung eines
an dramatik kaum zu übertreffenden
rennens auf position zwei liegend
passiert lewis hamilton seit langem ein
fahrfehler der britte fällt auf platz
neun zurück
es gelingt dem weltmeister aber noch in
der folge bis auf den zweiten platz
wieder vorzufahren max verstappen
gewinnt den großen preis der emilia
romagna vor lewis hamilton der in der
gesamtwertung weiter führt mit
schumacher wird sechzehnter sebastian
vettel muss ein auto mit getriebeschaden
abstellen
ein tor aber gerade vergessen dortmund
hat 4 zu 1 gegen werder bremen gewonnen
haben tech unbedingt korrigieren um
himmels willen so viel vom sport war das
dankeschön sonne gibt es morgen nur im
norden sonst überwiegen die wolken vor
allem in einem streifen von der eifel
bis zum bayerischen wald gibt es schauer
am nachmittag sind im osten auf gewitter
möglich
9 bis 18 grad marietta slomka begrüßt
sie im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
hier ist morgen wieder christian sievers
dran das gesamte heute team dank für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen eine gute
woche